let's see if we can figure out what 4/3
minus minus 1/5 is and if you think you
know how to do it I encourage you to
pause the video and give it a go so when
you first look at this the thing that
might jump out at you is we have
different denominators here and so it's
not obvious how to subtract 1/5 from 4/3
when you have these different
denominators and the key is is to
rewrite each of these fractions so that
they have the same denominator and how
do we figure out what that same
denominator is well it's going to be a
common multiple of 3 & 5 and ideally
it's going to be the least common
multiple of 3 & 5 so how can we
calculate that well we could start with
the larger of the two numbers say 5 and
let's go through it's multiples and see
when we get to one that's divisible
perfectly by 3 so 5 is not divisible by
3 10 is not divisible by 3 15 is
divisible by 3 in fact 15 is 3 times 5
so I can rewrite both of these fractions
as something over 15 so what's 4 thirds
if I were to write it as something over
15 well to get from 3 to 15 in the
denominator we have to multiply we have
to multiply by 5 so if you multiply the
denominator by 5 if you don't want to
change the value of the fraction you
have to multiply the numerator by 5 as
well so you have to multiply the
numerator by 5 as well 4 times 5 is
going to be 20 so 4/3 is the same thing
as 20 15 all right now how would we
rewrite 1/5 as 1/5 as something over 15
so we're going to 15 in the denominator
well to go from 5 to 15 we get to
multiply by 3 so if we multiply the
denominator by 3 we have to multiply the
numerator by 3 as well so times 3 1
times 3 is just 3
so 4/3 minus 1/5 we can rewrite that as
2015 minus 3 15 and now this becomes a
lot more straightforward what is this
going to be well this is going to be a
certain number of 15 so we have 2015's
and we're taking away 3 of those 15 so
we are going to have
if you have 20 or something can you take
away three of them you're going to have
17 of those things in this case we
talked about 15 so this is going to be
1715 and if we wanted to write it as a
mixed number we could say 15 goes into
17 one time with a remainder 2 so it's 1
& 2 15 let's do another example let's
see if we can figure out let's see if we
can figure out what 7/10 7/10 minus
minus 5 eighths is 5 over 8 and I
encourage you to pause this video and
see if you can calculate it yourself
well just like we saw before we have
different denominators but we need to
rewrite them so that they have a common
denominator that way we can subtract and
so what's a common what's the common
multiple of 10 and 8 and ideally the
least common multiple doesn't have to be
but it keeps things a little bit simpler
well let's start with the larger of the
two numbers and then keep keep finding
in their multiples and find one that
that is perfectly divisible by the other
one by 8 so 10 is it perfectly just by 8
20 isn't 30 isn't 40 is 40 is a multiple
of 10 and it's a multiple of 8 in fact
it's the least common multiple of 10 and
8 so we can write rewrite both of these
fractions as something over 40 so that's
going to be something over 40 minus
something over 40 minus something over
40 is equal to something so 7/10 is what
over 40 well to get to go from 10 to 40
in the denominator we multiply it by 4
so to do the same thing in the numerator
multiply the numerator by 4 7 times 4 is
28 so 7/10 is the same thing as 28
fortieths and i let's do something do
the same thing with the other fraction
to go from 8 to 40 in the denominator we
have to multiply the denominator by 5 8
times 5 is 40 so if we multiply the
denominator by 5 we have to multiply the
numerator by 5 as well 5 times 5 is 25
so 7/10 minus five eighths is the exact
same thing as 28:48
- 25 40s and now this makes a lot of
sense it's going to be a certain number
of 40 it's if I have 28 fortieths and I
take away 25 of those 40 it's how many
fortieths am I going to have left well
I'm going to have three 40s left
28:40 it's minus 25 40 it's so I'm going
to have three 40s 28 minus 25 is 3 and
we are done 7 tenths minus 5/8 is 340
it's